ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show audio only episode
direct your rage at the citizens of
baltimore maryland i will be at
magooby's tomorrow night in timonium
which is not even baltimore it's like a
town outside of baltimore it's like if a
rest stop
became a town it's not a town i don't
know what it is
but i'll be at magooby's laugh house a
very fun but unfortunately named
comedy club and in order to get there
and do it on time we were unable to use
our temporary studio in hollywood
california and we are broadcasting uh
from
uh a room in a hotel and i don't want to
say which hotel even though
many of you will find that out anyway
because we had one crazy [ __ ]
already this is our first stalker of
course it's a dumb [ __ ]
it can't be some [ __ ] hot dude
who wants to [ __ ] me to death
some guy with a a
[ __ ]
hot fat fetish
he just wants to beat the [ __ ] out of me
with his [ __ ] and then blow our brains
out it can't be that
it's like some dumb yoga instructor
who's fat
well well good for me
good for me i have some dumb fat yoga
instructor who's stalking me of course i
would
of course i couldn't even get like some
hot
[ __ ]
guy or girl
and this slob
[Music]
shows up at the hotel that i'm staying
at
we came here to new york for a few days
i don't tell anyone
when i'm coming here because uh
i don't want to talk to them
and i don't want them to request
me to do things i don't want to do you
know people reach out to me do you want
to do my show it's
you know it's in a laundromat and uh
we're you know raising money for it no
no no no no no no
stay away from me
are certain clubs
where i miss the people
at the clubs but also i don't
you know that's part of life
i do in theory and in my head and in my
mind
but in reality i
i do not
so i don't even let them know i'm here
even though i would like to go
to see
some of those people but i wouldn't
do you know
i have this this very complex
relationship with with
that
i want to do it but i don't
but i do
and i will but i won't
so i'm here
incognito nobody knows where i am i'm
just shuffling around i did the red
scare podcast
with anahashin and adasha necrozova
brilliant cultural critics
hot [ __ ] uh i put up a photo with
them and you could tell a lot of my more
intelligent fans are like yo this guy
[ __ ]
women he's [ __ ] this
these [ __ ] and i'm like okay
fair enough
that whatever
but i didn't really tell anyone i was
here i was here for three days three
days you can't get all the you know if i
was here for two weeks i tell people but
it's three days i'm in and out
um we were going to do a sketch with
little sasquatch
at barstool sports
we could not figure one out in time
he came over to the hotel me him and ben
were writing
eating uh
sichuan chinese food szechuan really
good
spicy the middle of night no good
i wake up at 3 30 in the morning to a
phone call
from the
manager of the hotel the front desk
going
someone's here to see you
and and i know this fat [ __ ] is
listening to this
and i'll tell you right now
you're lucky i didn't walk down into the
lobby and beat the living [ __ ] out of
you because that's the next thing i will
do you fat [ __ ]
seriously
okay i'm staying at the same hotel with
harry and meghan markle okay my friends
who i thought when the phone rang at 3
30 in the morning i said well this is
the end of me
because they called in a favor
that's what i thought i thought they
called it a favor and like a guy dressed
up like a postmates delivery guy was
going to come in here and put a blow
dart in my neck
okay because you know meghan markle
heard what i've said and felt some sort
of way
so those two uh intellectual
heavyweights are also in the hotel along
with every other diplomat in new york
everybody's got havana syndrome here
nobody you know forks are sticking to
people's heads i'm just trying to get
the [ __ ] mustard sauce with the
fillet buff
and this fat [ __ ] [ __ ] pig
calls walks in here
waddles her ass in here
and
maybe she thought i had food but she
called
they call me 3 30 in the morning they go
cameron herron wants to see you
uh somebody's down here to see you i
said who they said cameron herron now
cameron herron is a
poor kid
who murdered a woman
with his car and her baby i talked about
it
two
episodes a month ago yeah about five or
six years kid in tampa good looking was
on tick-tock everybody was like he's too
hot to go to jail they put him in jail
you know real
he's a rough situation okay
i tried to make light of it whatever
it is what it is he's getting married
he's fine he's gonna be in jail but
he's doing better than most people i
know
24-year jail sentence most people i know
not doing as well as him
okay
so i hang up the phone now i'm terrified
cameron herron i don't know what's going
on
of course i think megan and harry are
drunk
and playing games
and that's literally for a minute
because you got to remember it's the
middle of the night it's the middle of
the night this is what i think i think
that harry and megan
cause they're like maybe in the
penthouse i don't know the penthouse 75
grand a night maybe they're not
springing for that who's paying for this
by the way diana left him money so he's
you know spending that and he has a
stipend or whatever i think the royals
are kind of like hush-hush just keeping
it you know what i mean
you can't have them staying at a clarion
you know what i mean or you should see
the hotel benza god
i mean ahara
they want stalkers in that hotel that
anyone comes in
so i think i don't i don't know what's
going on
i said
harry and megan are are are playing
games now
and they're they're they're calling me
in the middle of the night and they're
trying to give me havana syndrome
explain what havana syndrome is please
because there's people that listen to
the show who don't have any idea
where they are
so explain to them
so about about 140 people have got this
so far in like cuba in the u.s and a
couple other places and basically
primarily cia agents are getting this
right that's correct this isn't
something we don't think is going to be
widely dispersed through the population
no no no
i want to read the actual list of
symptoms but it is pretty crazy a lot of
people report that they only feel the
symptoms in their hotel room and by the
way they don't know how they get this
because it's a direct energy weapon it's
through like
microwave um
what would you call that time microwave
uh
waves microwaves i guess like not
throughout radiation through uh yeah
radiation yeah yeah
scaring me about this well [ __ ] the
last couple of days talk about how we
all going to get advantage well yeah as
soon as i walked in the hotel this is
the last place i'd want to be if i
wanted to get havana syndrome jamie
diamond's outside you're not going to
give anyone [ __ ] advantage syndrome
i'm going to [ __ ] him up he's still out
there by the way i just walked by of
course he is what's he going gonna do
where's he going
[ __ ] out there drinking wine
you think where's our friends all of our
unemployed friends are too many saints
in newark
spending their last 12 dollars
watching a movie
so they suspect that microwaves that are
the main suspect of this microwaves
microwaves yeah that's what they're not
staying in a hotel with microwaves how
does this work this dude they're because
they're
sick people are getting a little sick of
the cia's act
so the cia comes into the country and
starts pulling the playing games and now
these countries are fighting back using
microwaves yeah too well it's hard to
get mad at that so like you'll be
sitting in your room and all of a sudden
it feels like
you're you know when you roll the
windows down in the in the the uh
in the back seat i do it that'll happen
for like 30 minutes to like an hour you
have nausea headaches just weird
unexplained symptoms you don't know how
you got it and a lot of people think
it's this is russian intelligence doing
this okay so that's what then terrified
me he goes we're all gonna get havana
syndrome here
okay
well we don't have advanced syndrome i
have cuban sandwich syndrome because i
got a fat girl in the lobby she shows up
at four o'clock in the morning 3 30
and she gives this fake name cameron
herron then they call me back i said i
don't know who i i'm not i'm not
entertaining guess i'm asleep i said a
lot i go to 3 30 in the morning
what are we doing i hang the phone up i
go use the bathroom they call back they
go we're kidding
she was using a fake name she said it
was a joke here's her real name i said i
don't know who this is
i don't know who this person is
i don't want her here
the next day today we're recording this
when
today uh wednesday september 22nd
wednesday september 22nd
so if anything happens between now and
you know when we release this saturday
just know that we're recording it
wednesday you know there's like a
nuclear attack that we don't address
[Music]
it's also not as important as this
to me
unless it happens to me unless i'm
vaporized which again
i wouldn't be able to address it anyway
but
this woman then calls back and gives her
a real name and i go i don't know her
today she's in the lobby again
and we're on long island and i get a
phone call
that this woman is in the thing again i
explain to the people at this hotel
which is the hotel that megan and harry
stay at it's the best western
in times square
okay
that's where i stay when i come to new
york i say the best western yeah with
megan and harry
so meghan markle
harry me
the diplomats
havana syndrome
jamie dimon and this fat [ __ ]
are all here together trying to just
have a [ __ ]
a souffle before the end
okay
that's what this area of new york city
is called the upper east side it's
let's do a little wine and trees before
the end
the door
is slamming shut on the american century
but before it does let's sneak a little
cabernet in there
and a little chase
that's all that's all we're asking for
okay
no talk of revolution here
the quieted muted tones
of a group of people
um
accepting the ephemeral nature
of the civilization that they've built
you know with all its problems anyway
so this goliath beast of a woman
who like does yoga can you imagine
yoga is a real fat thing isn't it you
just sit around and like put your leg in
the air
so
that's what it is right isn't yoga you
just like drink smoothies like sit on
your ass i guess you could be really fat
and still do it but isn't it just
learning how to fart and stuff
[Laughter]
i haven't really done much of it but i
imagine that's the majority of it is
learning how to like open your body so
that you can pass gas which i imagine is
what this woman does so piglet
shows up again i tell him i said beat
her up i said i tell them on the phone i
said hit her you know like like [ __ ] her
up like i hate the cops i don't want to
get the cops involved but i'm like you
got a bunch of secret service you got
some ex-intelligence people just smack
around
you know put the head in the toilet
you know what i mean like just put hands
on her i literally said the guy go why
do you put some hands on her you do it
like casino open the door with her head
i have no problem bumping into my fans
ever i go hey what's up let's take a
photo whatever don't [ __ ] wake me up
at four o'clock in the morning you fat
[ __ ]
so i said listen open the door with her
head put her head in the toilet
kick her
a couple of you know body shots to the
kidneys [ __ ] her up
[ __ ] her up they obviously legally can't
do that i offered to pay extra for them
to rough her i say ray will you rough
her up
gruff her up a little bit but they threw
her out
took her name she can't come in now
without trespassing
but this is the level right now now i
gotta check in every hotel
unregistered guest she tried to call me
on instagram she tried to call ben
imagine's talking bad
she tried to call bad on instagram what
do you think she would have said
i don't know she sent me a message i was
i was going to show you because i saw it
on the way over here get the message
yeah because this is interesting she
said something about you being in new
york uh she said i don't know why he's
here
i'm gonna read it exactly though and
then i'm gonna this is this is payback
because i've always said stalkers are
funny because they are you know like
whatever somebody says i'm trying to
protect taylor swift look at that
yeah so this woman goes why is he here i
don't understand what's going on and
miss call miss call on instagram yeah
yeah she's a little terrifying why is he
here i don't understand what's going on
and it looks like she's here to punch
you in the face
that's why i'm here
but this is what's going on we got a
psychopath here
these stars imagine stalking me it's the
lowest level i mean what a horror
what an embarrassment
to stalk me
stalking a podcaster
mark marin told us he has a stalker she
just like hangs outside of his house she
leaves that oils on his porch yeah and
the cops go we can't really do much yeah
the cops said the marine the cops go
yeah man she's out there he goes i know
she's out there he goes here she's like
out there she's also literally out there
but you can't do much you don't have a
lot of legal rights to stop these people
from uh stalking you i just thought
because we're in a really nice hotel
with a bunch of [ __ ] spooks
and you know intel guys here that we
could you know i don't know give go give
her havana syndrome
put to put her head in the microwave
what's the problem here i'm paying a lot
of money here
i'm paying a good amount of money put
her head in the [ __ ] microwave
kick her in the ass and get her out of
here
you think sebastian menescalco has
stalkers like they call them up
and they're like hey somebody's here
she's like
jesus [ __ ]
i know what are you doing what are you
doing with these
i'm telling you right now i got stalkers
stalkers
people are trying to kill me
that people are stalking me
they show up to my hotel i go what are
you doing
are you embarrassed
to be stalking me
are you crazy
you're a stalker
but you know i mean i think i handled it
maturely
i told him [ __ ] her up
yep but this is a psychotic individual
that would send a message and say why is
he here i don't understand what's going
on [ __ ] what do you mean what's going
on i'm [ __ ] freely traveling as a
citizen of the united states of america
what do you mean what's going on
that means someone's really sick
that's a sick person got to keep tabs on
them
i'll stalk her
like i'll have people stalk her too i
got a lot of friends without jobs
they'll sit outside your house
i got a lot of people that don't have
[ __ ] to do
by the way
i'll put them on a salary they could
they can sit around and ask ask you why
you go where you go
but it's one of those things when you
get known a little bit you're gonna
every now and then get a psycho yeah
you know the uh i don't understand
what's going on it's almost like oh but
tim isn't um continuing on with the plan
he's not supposed to be here right now
almost almost like in her head like
she's like he's not supposed to be here
he's supposed to be in
x y or z fulfilling the prophecy of
whatever like almost like q anon type
thing like why would she say i don't
understand what's going on well because
sometimes in these people's heads
they're in like some type of
relationship with you
uh that they they don't understand that
you do a show that they listen to
they think you're literally talking to
them and now [ __ ] i am but they think
i'm i'm literally talking to them
i will go down to the bronx right now
and spread a lot of money around i will
have teenagers stomp you out in front of
your apartment you understand
break your rib cage
this is not about violence against women
it's about violence against women
wman
specific
uh but no maybe these people are in a
relationship with you in their mind do
they think they think there's layers to
some i don't understand but it's
insanely inappropriate to show up at
somebody's hotel room and demand to to
to see them at 3 30 in the morning
and you told your wife ben's wife is all
spooked
yeah
yeah she was excited she was a little
scared she was she was she was scared
that the woman wasn't gonna kill me
she was scared that the woman was thrown
out
then now that's another plan that she's
hatched it's not gonna go anywhere
they know they're in the will now so
everything's like you know
well listen i mean you know this is part
of what we're gonna have to deal with i
guess as a show
gets more popular people are why are you
looking disturbed what are you looking
at uh i'm seeing the previous message
she sent me what is it it says hey
paulie
i hope you're well
since you chad's don't watch makeup
tutorials
here it's the same as my conspiracy or
scandal follow the money here's a link
to the evolution of morphe has been
linked to everyone in the beauty
community who has had controversy the
last two years yeah morph is like some
uh it's a like a makeup brand that was
involved with james charles that's what
it seems yeah this chick's takes on
dobrik are quite good too
so and she calls me call me polly for
some reason
yeah
is there any chance this is gabby petito
would gabby petito fake her own death
gain weight
and then stalk me
we covered the whole gabby potato thing
on patreon i will say this
uh i'll address the tweet that people
are getting angry about uh don't go to
national parks which i think is uh
i think that's and people go no you're
unhealthy and fat and that's why you
don't like national parks you go no i'm
not a murderer that's why i don't like
them they seem to be frequented by
killers
lots of people that murder other people
hang out there
a lot of people disappear national parks
had somebody on the patreon
who wrote an entire book about it john
billman yeah and what is the book called
uh let me pull that up
i love how he has the name of the guy
but not the name of the book you would
think i thought for a minute he pulled
up the name of the book but he somehow
has the name of the guy
and not the name of the it's like an
amazing well hey any any problems with
the episode it's havana syndrome
the cold vanish
people go out for like a light jog and
they're gone gone and then
you know you could keep blaming mountain
lions and bears but let's be honest
i think there's something else going on
i don't know what it is i don't want to
find out
i'm just saying it's not exactly the uh
you know
safest place to be
at people like you're victim blaming
you're trying to make a joke out of this
and i'm like you know hey
do we need a trial yes we explain it on
the bonus episode we need a trial
to get us out
of where we're at
with covin
everything people are still talking
about tick tock it's like that should be
over already
coveted should be over already
we're living in a hangover right now
of of news that should be overrated this
should have been flushed down the toilet
already the old turlet
but we're just circling the train here
and we need an o.j simpson style it'll
never be oj but something good juicy
that we could sink our teeth into to
help us get over this hump blue chew is
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets at a fraction of the cost
imagine that
you could take them any time day or
night so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations and no waiting in
line at the pharmacy bluetooth tablets
are made in the usa and prepared and
shipped direct to your door in a
discreet package with bluetooth
everybody
is excited to see the postman
bluechew.com
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free
when you use promo code td at checkout
that is absolutely free
just pay five dollars shipping visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information again try
it absolutely free just pay shipping
when you use promo code td
at checkout and it's a great way to
support the podcast we thank bluechu for
sponsoring the podcast
keebs hair loss is great i have a friend
that's using it and he's thrilled two
out of three men will experience some
form of hair loss by the time they're 35
more than 50 million men in the us
suffer from male pattern baldness
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both
it's a simple stress-free way to keep
your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
so you don't have to leave your home
low-cost treatment started just ten
dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions discrete packaging and
proven results keebs has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so you want to act fast
this is the way to keep your own hair it
is the most natural way to fight
baldness so if you're ready to take
action prevent hair loss go to k
e e p s dot com
tim dillon to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon i'm
telling you you're not gonna regret it
it's the best thing that's ever happened
to america and the world is people being
able to keep their hair
what is going on in texas
uh well right so right now in del rio
is a city where a lot of where is del
rio del rio is that where joe rogan is
building a new comedy club
it's it's somewhat far away from austin
probably about four or five hours is it
not in del rio
aren't we all building a new comedy
scene in del rio or no no no so what's
going on there so we got haitian
migrants that are moving from central
and south america to do comedy
[Laughter]
yes
perhaps okay perhaps i don't know what
their dreams are have they heard because
we put up that bat signal
go on
so a lot of them you remember in 2010
you remember the massive earthquake in
haiti do not uh there was the one that
pretty much decimated i don't remember
and it's not because it didn't affect me
and i'm a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] white guy it's because of
havana syndrome
so although i am usually
paying very close attention to the
tragedies of the world havana syndrome
so there was an earthquake in haiti in
2000 i do remember that a little it's a
little bit of the i get it it's coming
through the haze it was really it was a
really bad one i believe you yeah um so
uh yeah patrice had that bit about it
when people see disaster they yeah yeah
so jerk it off brilliant yes so um
so a lot of these you know haitian
people came over to
south america and central america and
now they're making their way up through
del rio a lot of people think it's from
the recent one
well no they've just been down there and
there's there's been rumors through like
social media that they were letting
people in through del rio for whatever
reason and so now they're all coming
into that city gotcha and that that the
border wall was supposedly down and then
governor abbott declared a state of
emergency and everybody's just kind of
losing their mind we were watching
tucker
he is in a wheelchair who's taking him
seriously
how did he lose his legs he was going
for a jog after a storm
the guy's tree in someone's yard fell on
him and paralyzed him and he like sued
and then he gets money every month for i
feel like this is a lie
but whatever
god bless the governor of texas
now
the the haitian migrants
are why they're under a bridge
and then the state of texas has sent
people out on horseback that's what i've
seen yeah yeah which is it's not a
phenomenal look yeah they're using rains
like whips to round up haitian
immigrants they're not really using the
whips they're they're they're using the
reins on the horses the way the photos
are taken i see it looks like they're
lassoing
the migrants
but we gotta can we not with the horses
for a minute can we just
i understand that we they always want to
bring the horses out in texas for crowd
control but it you know it does look a
little bad
in the photos
right yeah it doesn't look good it looks
a little django unchained so why don't
we just
you know
i don't know
let's just
but
i guess the horses are
in their minds they're saying it's
necessary it's good for crowd control
none of the migrants have had covet
tests so they want to be you know
i guess if you're on a horse you're kind
of six feet away yeah that's true right
there are like supposedly reports of 10
to 15 000 people this is a lot of people
it's a lot of people in del rio
and they're here and the debate is
the same debate that we that's been
going on for a very long time
how many immigrants
can america absorb
what
does an american citizen owe
to people coming over the border
and
how can you
maintain
a society
with all of these questions this is you
know
the same debate the same argument that
we've been having
and which would make you know if we
weren't doing all these things around
the world that created the conditions
for a lot of this migration
like if we weren't you know
when people get mad at the afghan
migrant they're like well now they're
gonna come here well well yeah
because we spent
20 years there
but if we weren't doing those things you
it would be more clear
like this debate
but we've been going all over the world
overthrowing governments creating chaos
and creating situations
where
you have refugees
that are then flooding into europe
in the uk and in the us
it doesn't mean that the people that are
concerned about immigration are wrong
i think those concerns are valid i don't
think they're racist i don't think
they're xenophobic i don't think
certainly some of them are right but i
think the the main concern
of how many immigrants can a country
absorb and at what pace
is largely economic
and that's really always been the case
to have these
you know
uh immovable opinions on these things
like aoc seems to have or some people on
the right seem to have don't make any
sense to me there are periods of time
when you need more immigrants to come in
and then there are periods of time
one might argue a pandemic skyrocketing
wealth inequality
uh
lots of issues already a fair amount of
immigrants in the country already that
haven't been legalized
um
that during a period like this period
you may not need as many
or you may want to hold off bringing
more in
until you've figured what's going on you
figured out what's
uh a fair process to bring people in but
just making that point has already made
me a nazi
in the in the eyes of somebody who says
no
no human is illegal
borders are inherently racist we cannot
have a country uh america as a country
is racist
we should give it back to the native
americans we're all on stolen land and
you go what does this mean
what is the plan how does all this work
and then they go i'm just gonna watch
the met gala
and you go but you just said a lot that
we're on stolen land and we got to give
the country back but who gives it back
first and they go i'm going to now tweet
about the real housewives for an hour
you go but wait a minute what about the
country in the stolen land so you're on
stolen land tweeting about the real
housewives
nobody's serious about any of this
mullen said once you know all these
politics are it's all aesthetic it's all
optics it's how i look to the rest of
the world but nobody's serious about any
of these things just like i don't know
how many people are serious about saying
we should never have another immigrant
come into america again that's not
realistic either
right especially when you have all these
baby boomers retire and you're going to
need immigrants to come in uh and be in
fields like healthcare that's going to
be a booming and rapidly exposing
industry a rapidly expanding industry
and exposing industry probably because a
lot of those nursing homes will need to
be exposed for like beating and robbing
the boomers but this time they'll
deserve it
i will put my parents in a nursing home
where i know they're going to get
roughed up and stolen from
but that's where we're at here but it's
that inability to have a logical
discussion about any of this that's just
why you you know you know you kind of
have to put your head in the sand here
but i mean just i would say just you
know maybe you know
not with the horses
that's all
it shouldn't look like a scene out of a
movie
try i mean there's got to be someone in
texas that had to make that point go hey
man if we go out there with horses i
mean you know what
you know what this is going to look like
what well they're haitian and
we're gonna ride in there on horses
you see
no
you remember that period of time
when
black people were enslaved yeah
those like a thousand years well and it
wasn't
but
a lot of the imagery from today's
events may make people think of that
time
i guess that conversation was not had
i guess nobody had that
discussion
you know well abbott remedied it looked
like because he just put a wall of cars
uh right there on the border
that's all he did he just parked a bunch
of cars
that's good what is that gonna do texas
governor abbott creates steel barrier of
vehicles to block migrants from entering
u.s that's right american muscle cars
baby yeah
that's all american cars are good for is
just to block immigrants from coming in
you know
we finally found a use for
american autos
we just put them on a
put them on the wall
i mean
if there was a better way because then
the people that are all pro-immigration
are like no one should ever have to
assimilate or learn english and then you
go how do they get jobs
how are they going to get jobs how are
they going to work how does this all
work nobody has any interest in the
practical applications of any of their
ideas
no one has any interest in taking it
it's all just about the perfectly
crafted opinion
the perfectly crafted take
hot take economy
send it out there in a tweet and then
we'll go watch uh you know all these
morons are at the emmys
right that are all offended by this
they're at the emmys
what do they imagine
that does for any of these people
by the way all these people that just
got here from haiti
what do you imagine you walking around a
ballroom in a gown
and getting a trophy for your work on
hacks
or
ted lasso does for these people that are
living under a bridge
because they really believe they believe
when they give these speeches that like
the people in haiti want to be on ted
lasso
or whatever show i don't even know what
shows are on anymore i don't know
i'm googling it right now to like i
don't even know what shows or
i have the full list of winners here
hacks right
uh you got uh yeah ted lasso which led
all comedies with 20 nominations wow
they really sweep yeah you got a on the
drama side you got the crown
yeah
uh
the mayor of east town mayor of east
town yeah well that's what these people
think they think that people under the
bridge
uh because when they when they're like
when they're like
you know speaking into the camera after
they've won the award they're like you
know this is for everybody out there
whose dream it is to make art
i'm telling you never give up they think
they're talking to the people in del rio
under the bridge
that came here to be on mayor of east
town
they think they've come here to be on
the crown
i don't you know listen we're past
solutions in this country you know we're
still looking for solutions
i don't know what to tell you poor colin
quinn just got covered again vaccinated
had it no symptoms no no symptoms
but you know he tweeted out he's like
everyone that was around me at the
cellar
i mean here's the thing man if we're
gonna have all these cases where nobody
has any symptoms maybe we should just
stop keeping track of cases
and start keeping track of
hospitalizations only
michael tracy is running around all
these different colleges because they're
just shutting down colleges now and
michael tracy has become like this
interesting
kind of version of nelk
he's like he's going around from college
to college just like
trying to defend these kids right to
party and [ __ ]
whereas like colleges now like they
don't let they don't really allow you
to congregate in the manner that you
would have been allowed to do
pre-pandemic although even though
a lot of their populations are like 98
vaccinated
so michael tracy has just been like
leading the charge
trying to liberate
college students
from the draconian
covet measures
that are and they're in certain parts
it's a lot of like ivy league schools i
don't think the southern schools care
but i think it's a lot of ivs a lot of
northeastern schools yeah michael was in
connecticut specifically yeah
schools on the west coast
i know some people that go to schools
are like we've not had any
uh i mean i've not worn a mask in new
york but we were asked for proof of
vaccination
getting a piece of pizza in staten
island
which was weird
because you figure staten island
trump country
back to blue
but
they're like yeah show us that vax
which means that a lot of these people
are going to get
ratted out
they're going to get fined
there's probably a sizable hefty fine
that they'll get because no nobody's
hearts in it you can tell
as it shouldn't be
but like every other bureaucratic thing
there's a fine coming down yeah
like i remember when they just banned
cigarettes
and
like
they would be like all right you can't
really
hey you can't smoke here
but it'd be like a guy telling you that
who like really
his heart was not in it
he was just like wanting to
smoke himself
and he's like yeah they you know
you can't smoke here you used to be able
to just smoke anywhere you want it i
mean not anywhere but in every bar when
did they ban smoking in new york let me
see
when i was growing up restaurants had
smoking sections
i mean which is unfathomable to me now
because
wow 2002 that recent huh oh yeah
i didn't realize no i mean restaurants
had
smoking sections when i was in high
school
it's wild to think about yeah that is
because the smell of cigarettes by the
way
is so strong
and it used to just everything would
smell like that
airports people would smoke in planes
and now nothing smells like cigarettes
every now and then you smell a cigarette
as you walk down the street you go oh
but nothing smells like cigarettes but
for decades everything smelled like
cigarettes it looks like new york was
one of the last to do it because texas
was 75. that's why i never saw it
growing up at all texas
banned cigarettes when 1975 smoking in
indoors why
uh 1975 texas first enacted legislation
restricting smoking in public places
including primary secondary schools
elevators theaters movie houses pretty
much everywhere i thought they were free
that's what i thought too wow
but new york 2002 baby
well new york used to be a wild city
interesting see that dead flies in the
face of everything that everyone
believes about new york versus texas
that like new york is this
city of liberal [ __ ] and texas is
like the city of like
hey man
grab life by the balls
see what happens but texas in 1975's
like do not light up inside
in
yeah it's wild huh but yeah it's really
wild i think everyone was dying back
then in texas from like you know they
called marble reds cowboy killers yeah
cause cowboys would just smoke them on
down
so maybe there was more death i don't
know
you're allowed to smoke in texas now
if you're if you're pregnant but you
have to
you have to carry the baby to term
and low birth weight and whatever but
you gotta
you can smoke if you're pregnant but not
if you if you go if you're gonna abort
the fetus
that can't that can't happen
i love it we're being stalked by by a
[ __ ] lunatic
we should send her to del rio
introduce the haitians to her be like
are you sure you really want to come
here
you got to realize people come to this
country are desperate they're desperate
yeah this is not a really great place to
come right now
truly you've got to be desperate yeah
you can't have any other options
if sweden would take you you'd be an
idiot to come here
how stupid would you have to be
if like norway or denmark would take you
and you go nah i want to go to america
that would be crazy
you know
i told ram like maybe the moves to just
get a
buy a house in another country
that might be the move
to just have another
place outside of america
you know just to see like
if things go real bad here
i mean if things go bad it'll probably
go bad everywhere but i could live in a
fishing village in like sweden
yeah you know
that would be fine yeah
where were we uh
right before we came here
we were in um
and what is that thing my it's now off
the internet right
that what is it
article about san antonio
it's it's a lie it says i was banned
from corpus
christie christi yeah yeah let me pull
that up this is not true
this is from a news site that's like
fake
and my agents were all like worried
about it because they thought that i was
like banned from
corpus christi which is one of the worst
cities in america comedian tim dillon
banned from corpus christi texas after
disrespecting selena which i didn't do
yeah i made a joke about it on the
podcast
yeah and then get over hey hey hey
corpus christi with selena
get over it
hey hey hey john lennon get over it
same thing
stop
strumming your guitar outside of the
dakota on the anniversary of his death
move on
is that okay
is that equal enough for everyone
i think john lennon probably was
more musically talented than selena am i
allowed to say that although she was
really good
yeah this article saying the mayor
banned you from the city it's a joke it
can't be true the article it's all at
the websites of china yeah it's it's
dumb yeah
it's like like a fun joke yeah
i don't think they have a mayor
i know that corpus christi texas has a
mayor
who's the mayor selena's ghost
selena's ghost sits on the council there
and has a vote
who's the mayor the woman who killed her
there is no mayor
please i'm never going back to corpus
christi in my life sorry
i'm not
i'm not gonna yeah life is really too
short yeah it's bad
it made me think maybe go man austin
what a place
what a [ __ ] awesome place but you
know of course my agents and everybody's
nervous you're like were you banned from
a city
stop
you please
grow up
these are not the brightest people in
the entertainment business by the way
i hope i'm not surprising anybody but
they're not exactly well read
this is not exactly
i've said it before the people that
become agents for the most part are the
black sheep of wealthy families
their brothers and sisters have
accomplished things
they work at goldman sachs
they're a surgeon
at johns hopkins
they work in finance at a high level
you know they're in academia
these people
are selling clowns
you know
you know they're routing a tour for some
16 year old tick tocker
it's a it's you know
it's not a prestige position anymore
it's been a long time since ari gold in
entourage right
remember that oh yeah a long way there's
about four of those guys there's about
four people in the business left that
are like ari gold and the rest of them
are like shot
truly
the rest of them are like [ __ ]
you know
i mean there's not a ton of those like
high powered
[ __ ] you agents slick back hair quick
quick fun sharp
hopping out of a [ __ ] porsche like
[ __ ] you
my client you know they're terrified
they're just scared now they're now
they're quivering they're
you know they're like oh my god did did
my client say something to a woman at
7-eleven is it on is it on video [ __ ]
are we [ __ ] who did he rape
who what happened
second year of college what what
happened
who do they got
all these guys now are just they're just
terrified
so that you know that would have been a
great season of entourage if ari gold
just had to kept dealing with like the
me too's
from vince and everyone else
like that was the entire season
arigal's like wait a minute she was
drunk
vinnie vinnie vinnie listen listen
sophomore year
queen's college
you were to party
do you remember this
she was drunk
vinny i need you to listen i know you're
having fun
i need you to walk out onto the balcony
you need to hear me right now we got a
big [ __ ] problem
vinnie we then i need you to hear me
right now we got a big [ __ ] problem
there's an article coming out tomorrow
okay do you know what date rape is
i'll tell you what it is it means you're
not an aquaman 4. that's what it [ __ ]
means okay
jesus [ __ ] christ doesn't matter
about facts vinny
jesus do you know what trauma is
repressed trauma
well i'll tell you what it is it means
that even though she didn't feel like
that at the time she felt like that a
decade [ __ ] later did you keep up
with her you got to send these some
[ __ ] [ __ ] a text
[ __ ]
who is his assistant lloyd yeah lloyd do
we have a mole at the l.a times jesus
[ __ ] christ
it's just the me too season of entourage
yeah yeah
that made hollywood look so much fun
yeah one guy one guy gets famous he
brings his three friends along
and that that is part of the hollywood
now it's just it's really the majority
of that is that's what the tick tick
tock young social media kids do
somebody gets famous they live in a
house with a bunch of their friends
um they all throw a lot of parties they
make a good amount of money
and uh
then it should end and it should be over
already but you know
they're still hanging on to that
they're still hanging like the demilio
should not have a show
it should we should be nearing the end
of that act
but
nothing ends
so now we're just dragging everything
out
you see the dances now these kids are
like in their mid-20s they're not even
into it now they're like the dancers on
tick-tock
they they're starting to like they look
old some of these children
i'm like they're starting to look like
they're like
like adults yeah like they have to
stretch before they go into yeah they
look like they're like
they're like dealing with problems
i'm like this this isn't fun anymore
it's not fun anymore he's now their job
and they're just doing it and you go
just shut this thing down
just shut this thing down please
they did it with the other one they did
it with vine just shut just shut it down
shut it down send these kids back to
school
mask them up and
i don't know what they're doing make
them do live shooter drills
they need to be in school doing live
shooter drills
by the way i love all the people that
want you know want their kids in school
and they're like these they
shouldn't be
learning at home they need to be in
school with their friends doing live
shooter drills
they need to be in school and they need
to be practicing what happens when
someone comes in here with a gun
do you know how much were the
experiences we're robbing these kids of
not being in school
learning how to survive a violent attack
by a by a
mal-adjusted
unmedicated heavily armed member of
their class
you can't get that on zoom
you can't get those experiences on zoom
they'll never have that year of their
life back
what if parkland
was unzoomed
they never would have had those
experiences do you know what kind of
bond that fostered
none of those kids will ever forget that
year and it wouldn't have happened if
they were on zoom
it wouldn't have happened
i want to be a parent who goes
to one of these
uh school things that makes that point
they need to be in person learning
so that they can learn how to defend
themselves and each other
from their fellow classmates
who we have driven insane
with a steady diet of fast food
no attention
horrible violent entertainment and we
have also armed
and and our children need to learn
how to defend themselves from that
inevitable
nightmarish situation that is all too
common
that cannot happen on zoom i'm sorry
i feel better as a parent knowing my
children
are in school
safely learning how to deal with an
active shooter situation
that will happen because of the society
that we've set up it seems
pretty inevitable
how many school shootings have we had
since we've gone back to school by the
way well did you see that 13 and 14 year
old were planning like a columbine yeah
what were they doing over in florida
yeah they were in a florida middle
school and they were two hours away from
marjory stoneman douglas uh so i think
they were inspired by it but by parkland
and and these were like kids they're
like babyface chubby fat little kids 13
year old kid yeah and they're planning a
massacre massacre absolutely what's
going on with the society
hopefully these haitians get to have
that experience we're like their
children at 13 are planning uh
a massacre so it looks like these kids
were basically extensively studying the
columbine shooting the investigators
found
they found knives guns
they were learning how to purchase
firearms on the black market and how to
construct pipe bombs
hmm
they're 13 they were purchasing firearms
on the black market yeah and probably
instructional articles like on the dock
you want to hear
how's your son well
um to be honest he was purchasing
firearms on the black market
and trying to learn how to make pipe
bombs
you know
that's not good
right
i'm not a parent
but i'm guessing
that that's not good
now what happens to these kids
uh it says here that um
they were
they the the authorities the two
students are well known to the
authorities deputies having visited
their homes nearly 80 times combined
both boys met the criteria for
evaluations at a mental health facility
and were assessed before being detained
so they're like i guess detained but you
know not in
you know prison they've been to their
homes 80
times
yeah very thorough here man 80 times huh
i'm betting these kids are a real
problem yeah this seems like they were
really gonna go like
all out here
maybe i mean at a certain point
if the cops have been to their houses
that combined 80 times should the cops
just kill them
like literally and i'm not trying to be
insensitive but if you're buying like
trying to get pipe bombs at 13
i don't want to see what 19 is
so why don't we just kill them
like we killed that witness in the uh
the dokar tsarnaev case tamerlan's and i
have the boston uh bomber the fbi
invented a reason they whacked that guy
even though like you know four to six
fbi agents went to go interview him
supposedly he was some kind of threat so
you just shot him
why don't they just get rid of those
kids
oh supposedly these kids were also
recruiting others to participate
wow
well that'll teach you a lesson you
always got to keep it small
they're spending 21 days and secure
juvenile nile detention well that'll
help
you got to kill him
truly
i mean there's what are you i'm not no
i'm not kidding what are you going to do
with them
they're going to be a nightmare their
entire lives
you have to kill those kids you kind of
do you have to execute both of those
kids
there's absolutely no way they're going
to come back there's never ever a story
where it's like yeah i was building pipe
bombs and getting weapons off the dark
web at 13 but
now you know i'm just a really excited
uh
barista
i just have a zest for life and i love
making the coffee
i mean i think maybe they're too far
gone
kill them
i understand that there's redemption
arcs in people's lives if you've had one
to a degree i'm not saying that uh you
know
these things are impossible i'm saying
it's a real steep hill to climb from
pipe bombs at 13 to any you know to
being a productive member of society
kill the kids
their names are uh pruitt and bird
jesus christ kill them
i mean kill them now
why can't cops have ever killed people
that need to be killed
pruitt and bird
they should be publicly hung
their little fat legs kicking out
we we we have to
pruitt and bird yeah they knew where the
gas lines were to the school and
everything they really were just going
to take the whole thing down kill him
kill him
say it was uh i don't know
do what you always do say they came at
you
what about their parents any quote from
pruitt and bird's uh parents on this no
they've they've stayed out of the media
on this one it seems
i'm guessing and i don't know but i bet
they're not from a great home
i can only see the backs of them here
two the children yeah yeah here let me
see these [ __ ] monsters
dude
yeah i mean and they're just friends
these kids right
they're they're like they're not
brothers they're like just friends just
friends supposedly i think bird was the
mastermind here or maybe pruitt let me
see
yeah bird's the mastermind he's the
older one he's 14. don't you think
anybody at pruitt's house goes you
cannot hang out with bird anymore
why i don't know the cops were here like
60 times
don't you think around number 20 when
the cops come to talk to you about your
kid
you should just
not
allow them to do whatever they're doing
hey we're back again all right sorry
pruitt get in here
you can't go to birds anymore
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're doing
but the cops are here this is the 28th
time they're [ __ ] here pruitt
they're saying you're trying to get pipe
bombs you little freak
jesus
there were plenty of warning signs in
this case deputies were called to the
home of 13 year old connor pruitt 60
times nearly 20 times to the home of 14
year old philip byrd which has many
asking should parents be held
accountable if their children plan
them now
do not waste time for christ
i do not understand why we cannot
execute children
[Music]
they'll do it in texas
right
yeah
they should oh yeah
well they're 13 and 14 and they they
were responsible for their actions
i would put them both in little electric
chairs
and cook them
put them on death row and cook them
cook those kids
zap them
they're not gonna listen this is an
uncomfortable truth that many people
listening to the show are probably not
happy about
if the cops have come to your house 60
times about your kid
you're you [ __ ] up
i don't know what you did
but the kid's bad bad news
there's nobody that comes out of that
and becomes like something you know yeah
yeah
it's not like one day bird is gonna
start dating greta thundberg
and doing a
you know carbon emissions speeches he's
in trouble
i'd love to see the look on their little
faces when a judge sentences them both
to death
by electric chair
put them in old sparky and cook them
how about that
that's my position
and cook my stalker too put her an old
sparky get her a bigger chair that fat
lump
and don't try to kill me i don't think
anyone's gonna care they won't trust me
so it looks like um
people have signed a uh it says here
there's a petition created by the parent
of the children and the school district
of lee county as close to 2 800
signatures as of saturday morning it
calls for the 13 and 14 year old boys
who are arrested september 9th
to be kept out of the schools and
suggest they be homeschooled
i think home is the problem
school is also not good kill them
the problem isn't
where they are physically the problems
that they exist on earth
kill them
truly
you want them at home
homeschooling is not an option here
right they've been homeschooling
themselves in [ __ ] gorilla warfare
lethal injection if you want to be kind
you don't have to use old sparky
hit him with the needle get it over with
truly
there should be a program that kills
children
and we none of us should have a problem
with it i don't have any problem with it
i have i will sleep beautifully in this
lovely bed i'm in tonight knowing that
those two kids were held down while they
were screaming probably and tied to a
thing and if you've ever seen dead men
walking yes
then they're put up like christ with
their with their arms out on either side
and they said do you have any last words
and they go oh don't kill me and you go
yeah well whatever and then put the
needle in
and then you see their foot kicking and
then it stops kicking i will sleep
so soundly knowing that they've been
tied up and executed
you know what i hate here that they're
using that sir kensington's ketchup i
don't like that i like heinz
i like sir kensington's mustard shut up
the ketchup that fancy ketchup is stupid
yeah and heinz out of a glass bottle is
still the standard yes but
kill those kids
um
you've got back-to-back meetings errands
to run chores to take care of
what is the secret to clearing your
to-do list a little help from doordash
you can get dinner household essentials
and everything on your grocery list
delivered
ever pull into the driveway after a trip
to a grocery store only to forget that
you forgot one key ingredient for dinner
now you have options get the groceries
you need or a backup meal from your
favorite local restaurant delivered with
doordash you can really do all of your
shopping
online especially if you're busy
you're you may be doing a lot of work
you might have kids kids are back in
school there's a lot to do they have
play dates they have sports they have
dance they have
school plays they have whatever they
have
what do you need to do
help them with their homework focus
what what do you then do
doordash you can get all of your
groceries delivered cook them healthy
nutritious food
or you can get uh you know have a little
fun meal for them on a friday night or
something like that you don't have to
get in your car you don't have to drive
you don't have to expose yourself to
any unsafe
uh situations
out there
get what you want to eat right now
right to your door
with doordash
craving late night ice cream forgetting
that one key ingredient for dinner maybe
you want to stock up for the week with
doordash get everything in one app with
over 300 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood go to's
or your favorite restaurant chains like
popeyes chipotle or cheesecake factory
the kids will love it
buy the kids cheesecake
ordering is easy
and your items will be left safely
outside your door when you choose
contactless drop off for a limited time
our listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the doordish
app and enter code tim dillon that's 25
off up to 10 dollars in value with zero
delivery fees on your first order
download the doordish app in the app
store and enter code tim dillon and then
get cheesecake for the kids
don't forget that's code tim dillon
t-i-m-t-i-l-l-o-n
for 25 off your first order with
doordash
subject
to change in terms of plot
but
this is going to be a great
way
to manage your time
and your resources better go to the app
store enter code tim dillon
and if the kids are being good
get him a little cheesecake
tell them uncle tim and doordash are the
reason that they're eating cheesecake
on wednesday
you gotta always be one step ahead
of the big
government and the big corporations
and uh the national security state and
how do you do it
vpn
virtual private network
all of the institutions that i just
mentioned are trying to harvest your
information
selling it best case personally using it
against you in the future
worst case
um
so what do you want to do
expressvpn lets you change your location
online so you can control where you want
to think you're located
they have almost 100 different server
locations so you can gain access to
thousands of new shows this works with
any other streaming services too bbc
iplayer youtube and more it's great
everybody here uses it ben uses it
blazing fast speeds compatible with all
your devices encrypts all your data stop
paying full price for streaming services
and only getting access to a fraction of
their content protect your personal
information from being sold or harvested
by the government get your money's worth
at expressvpn.com
tim dillon that's expressvpn.com
tim dillon do not forget to use my link
to get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free
that's literally
three months which is 90 days
of expressvpn
absolutely 100 percent free if you use
the link expressvpn.com
tim dillon
[Music]
patreon this week is very funny with uh
gabby is there any new information on
that before we wrap this up the only
thing i've seen is they're just
searching that um brian laundry still
gone huh yeah they uh i i saw they had
called off the search and i thought they
gave up but it was just for today
that that's all it was they're looking
around in that park for him search for
gabby petito's fiance brian laundry ends
for the day at florida nature reserve
so they're just sort of digging around
there they're like everybody the search
is over but enjoy the grounds
you know
we're stopping the search
but we're we're having a dinner
when do they give up because this is the
fourth day now they've searched all day
and they're in there well no it's a
manhunt right i mean they give up when
they find them
i don't know how long that particular
search of the park will go on i think
he's probably not in the park
yeah at this point he's probably not i
think his family well here's the deal
right
if the guy uses a credit or debit card
he's caught right how much cash could he
have right who's giving him money how's
he living
probably family
someone is helping him out he can't hold
out for that much longer
mm-hmm
pruitt bird
listen
i hate to be the bearer of bad news but
they're gonna cook y'all
at the end of this month
they're gonna cook both of y'all in that
electric chair scare kids that would
scare kids right
wouldn't it scare kids
if you cook them
sometimes you got to think about what's
good for society and what's good for
society i believe is executing these
children without a trial
what about a firing squad oh nice like a
firing squad
where they were both
you know next to each other and no
blindfolds i want them to see it and we
just go at them
i mean
folks
if you're unwilling to murder two
children
to make a point i don't know why you
even pay taxes in this country
what do you think those taxes are going
to
we kill children all over the world why
why can't we kill our own that's a great
point it's a phenomenal point it's hard
to argue it's the only point
why we keep killing poor kids playing
soccer in pakistan let's kill these two
fat [ __ ] trying to murder everybody
drone strike their [ __ ] houses
timdylandcomedy.com
[Laughter]
for all the live shows coming up
uh if you enjoy the comedic stylings of
what i do
you'll love it live we're on a theater
tour with sam talent
ben avery will be on most of the dates
and it will be a
joyous occasion
filled with love i will not talk about
the
children
uh being electrocuted
at the shows
a lot
i will mention it
i might mention it as a good idea
um don't stalk your favorite comedians
and podcasters and show up their hotels
it's not right
yeah we've been having a lot of fun
and you know the audio only episodes we
always try to get to a studio
uh we have a studio in la that we're
trying to
we haven't found one quite yet but we
have one that we use temporarily
have we made any headway on the studio
front yes yes i'll be looking at some
stuff in two days via computer not in
person that's fine yeah
and he's gonna send you this
yeah our guy that we got through
business jason
our business manager oh and a couple of
things couple housekeeping things uh you
added uh extra shows in a couple cities
yes we've added extra shows in a couple
cities atlanta
sacramento
and the other one was atlantic city
so just so people know oh and pittsburgh
a late show was added we've added late
shows in pittsburgh sacramento atlantic
city and atlanta
keep buying uh tickets if you like we
appreciate it um
we're gonna have fun
and
kill your kids
if you have to
but if you don't you don't
you know
anything else that we need to uh maybe
subscribe to the youtube channel yeah
let's try to push our subscribers over
400 000 and turn the notifications on i
know like you guys still message me it
doesn't work or whatever but turn the
notifications on subscribe
yeah
it works for some people but you know
they don't they're not you know
we can't get anything going on over
there
we're making no money over there they
haven't given us a green dollar in
months man yeah
well this is
what happens when you
advocate killing children
but i dare listen to this and and you
know be like no it's they're just we
need to do more for them no we don't
no we don't
well no we need to you like listen to
them and hear them and no they might
just be bad
they may just be bad
you know
like
you know be funny we said jamie diamond
he's having dinner outside i wanted to
go up to him and be like my debit card
the strip like the strip on it doesn't
have you seen this like you know you're
sitting there with like some other like
really rich guy and his wife and i just
wanted to go there and go do you do you
replace these with with the you see the
strip
i don't get it
i go the chip takes longer
like inserting the chip takes long it's
not quicker
i understand it helps protect against
identity theft
anyway identity theft what's going on
there is that the russians
it would be kind of interesting to just
go up to him yeah just start talking
about like getting a loan for something
like can i get a loan i'm trying to make
a movie
i want to make a movie
okay
can i get a loan to make a movie
from you
jamie diamond
how funny would it be like if i was
dressed in a suit and i just went up to
him was like it's good to see you again
hey jamie good to see you again you
wonder if a guy like that would just go
like would he be like
trying to play he'd be like okay yeah
you know what i mean yeah because he's
met so many people yeah i don't know
what he'd how he'd play it i don't know
how he'd react he seems pretty cold
y'all see your chase no
i don't think so
i bet he's a cauldron of warmth
i bet he's just a fireplace and on a
cold day
sea of chase no he's cold he did seem
very cold it seemed like stone yeah yeah
yeah
that's how they all seem yeah the wife
seemed like she didn't wasn't allowed to
like make eye contact with them she
they're not even at the table anymore
they're the the the relationships at
that level are
i mean
the rich like that are a different
species
people don't understand that there are
different species they
they don't have the emotions that we
have
you can't
because then you end up not being rich
right um
they just really are
cold like kind of waspy
just whatever you're feeling just kill
it
keep it down
take a gulp of wine
a couple lasagnas little valium whatever
you need
to just kill that emotion
do it
you know
she's just sitting there eating you know
they're playing the big game they're in
the big game those people yeah they are
you know
they're just sitting there and you know
not eating great food
no the food where he was was okay it's
not great it's just it's in the
neighborhood it's a restaurant that a
lot of their friends go to
and it's in the neighborhood it's in the
hood
and it's just has that reputation of
yeah yeah i'm not going to mention i
don't want to get in trouble here i'm
not going to mention the name of the can
i mention the name of the restaurant i
don't see why not son ambrose it's a uh
it's
it's a place where people on the upper
east side you're like you know it's like
young moms like bring their kids and
they
the prep school kids they have like
gelato and then you know the women go
there too
they like split a salad
and they you know have like four glasses
of chardonnay
and
you know
a couple of pills and
go home to their loveless marriages
but he was outside in these you know
horrific like horse stalls that people
in new york are eating in
and the food is not great there but it's
you know a place where they you know
it's kind of like i lived in new york
for years and years and it's one of
those places i i like went to saunders
once for breakfast i was like this is
not good
i went with a friend of mine and and and
then creating a crazy michelle
uh but
yeah he was very stoic and cold looking
but that's how you get to be the ceo of
chase right
like nobody's like like you don't get to
be the ceo chase by being like you know
affectionate
you know
i don't know anything about him
his parents were loaded right
yeah they were he's not one of these
guys like blank fine like blank fight i
think came from like
the jewish projects or whatever
the lower east side or brooklyn maybe
i was i was confused that uh there
wasn't like tons of bodyguards around
cuz i thought those guys like there's
like kidnapping plots and stuff i don't
really know i don't know how many people
maybe there was somebody we didn't see
but i also don't know how many people
would recognize him i just recognized
him
uh yeah i mean he was
one of three sons of greek immigrants
theodore
and whatever and attended the browning
school what do you mean and whatever
and well then the the greek name it's
it's well why don't you try to sound it
out theodore and niallos
okay diamond
okay it's not a big deal his paternal
grandfather was a greek immigrant who
changed the family name from papadame
trio to diamond to make it sound french
and worked as a banker in smyrna now
athens or smyrna and athens georgia uh
or greece i believe greece yeah smyrna
okay
so that's that's his background
yeah they they come from people that did
things he went to tufts
and then harvard business school yeah
they usually there's a line of people
that have done things
not always
you know
it's not like you know jamie's father
jamie's mother was stalking podcaster
tim dillon
in the hotel
you know
it's usually like some type of
i should've went up to him and said
what do you think about 9 11
[Laughter]
just between me and you
what if i was what if you were the
waiter at san ambros and he walked up to
him and he went what are you
what do you think about 911
do you know anything about that
should i try to get a job at one of
these places
just so you can ask people just for a
gag yeah
because all these places are hiring
right
should i try to get a job
on the upper east side at one of these
rest like i would never get high i would
never get hired yeah
well your resume has a huge like gap in
it too
yeah but wouldn't they they'll run a
background she'll figure out who i am
but wouldn't it be funny if i could just
get a job for a day or two
to just
talk to every table about 9 11.
before i got fired
and i was like why am i getting fired
they're like you can't
hey
i know you have enthusiasm for the food
you know all the dishes you're very good
you know all the terms we didn't have to
explain to you like what a gremolata was
like you're good like that you're like
really good we're kind of really
impressed
the problem we're having
is that every single table said you've
brought up 911.
every single table
every single table you've had
has complained
you've worked here an hour
you've had three tables
all of them have said
when i said how's everything going
the waiter continually and incessantly
talks about 9 11.
so we're gonna give you a warning
but the next time we have to talk to you
about this
okay
and then they'd fire me they'd go okay
you asked jamie dimon for money
we have to let you go
it is incredibly inappropriate wildly
inappropriate
to ask jamie dimon for money
i would say can i get
can i get a little money from you
like now
you're gonna tip me later can i just get
it now
[Laughter]
can you give me like forty dollars now
cash
well
maybe the next
what if pruitt and bird do become like
very successful
hmm you know they turn it around they
turn it around yeah cause that's what
america is about it's comeback stories
turn they turn it around
they're not gonna end up in angola
what if they both turn it around
they're they're the ceos of chase
you think pruitt and bird are going to
be the ceos of chase
i'm asking
i mean man they got a long way to go
from being two little fat school
shooters in southwest florida to being
ceo of chase but that's america
that's america from two fat little
school shooters to rising the ranks the
ceo of chase
i could see i could see him having a
house on center island where we went
today
i think it'd be great if jamie dimon
mentored both of them that's a tv show
i'd watch
why doesn't jamie dimon take pruitt and
bird to son ambrose
and get them gelato maybe that's all
they're missing is a good pistachio
gelato yeah or hazelnut
and jamie dimon has to walk pruitt and
bird through the upper east side of
manhattan
bring their fat asses
into ralph lauren get them clothes
and ask them you know talk to them
and he looks at them he goes listen i
know all you people want to do is kill
but at my company we kill without firing
a shot
and they go what do you mean by that
jamie
he goes we could kind of do whatever we
want for example during the mortgage
crisis there were tons and tons of uh
accusations of fraud but we paid
billions and billions of dollars to stop
the investigation
stop the inquiry into our company
and we kept billions and billions of
dollars
you know earned through fraudulent
practices
because
we were able
to
bully the federal government
doesn't that sound like fun
you get bullied at school a lot right
yeah
that's why you're two fat little school
shooters
but wouldn't you like to be able to be
in a position to bully the cops that
bullied you and i don't even mean the
cops i mean everybody
the politicians that make the laws
the federal reserve what's that doesn't
matter i just mean we bully everybody
the only people we don't believe are the
tech guys
they're the only people we don't bully
well why can't we bully them says bird
obviously had like ice cream on his
mouth
jamie dime's like wipe your face
he's like well we can't believe them
because they know everything about us
what we think who we are i mean
they're you know they're unbelievable at
this moment
you know and pruitt and bird are like
this guy's [ __ ] cool
and jamie diamond like he just feels
like for the first time in his life like
you know he really loves these
fat little school shooters from southern
florida
and and he just takes them in as like
his proteges
you know
and he raises them
and it's like a beautiful story
and he teaches them that like you don't
have to you can devote
all of your murderous violent
energy into succeeding
at finance
you just got to get a gym bag
and the right clothes
take adderall
learn how to stare at a computer
learn how to acquire friends and
relationships based
solely on
you know
monetary gain
he taught them all these things and
i mean that's your only hope
but i mean that's a [ __ ]
beautiful story
because that's the best version of those
two kids yeah
the best version of those two kids
become financial criminals
you know
for a great institution like chase bank
do you think like kevin hart who has a
partnership with chase i will one day
have a partnership with chase
or do you think that
because of a lot of the content that
i've made
that isn't likely not likely
[ __ ]
sometimes i realize i really shot myself
in the foot
you know
doing the show
i could have been on hacks
to show about uh
gene smart who's a legend because we say
she is
now we're just saying
by the way
is every woman over 40 a legend can
someone help me out
is every woman over 40 alleges is my
mother a legend she had a mental
institution give her an emmy
what did gene smart do
numbs
i mean she's good in hacks right
but what did she do again was she on
loveboat i'm i'm googling it right now
what the hell does she even do
everyone just says she's a legend and
every time she talks everyone starts
crying
so jean smart was on um
designing women
with delta burke yeah uh okay
uh she was on frasier
as what
um
i don't remember her i watched every
episode of that uh
it's not showing up immediately
interesting what else uh let's see here
she's just had a long career
she was in big mouth uh she was in 24.
what's big mouth
uh that remember the jenny slate show oh
yeah yeah i'm sorry i should know that
show it's
nick kroll and jenny slate and
my buddies
uh she was in uh
watchmen
she's worked she's worked
she's worked sweet home alabama
with reese witherspoon that's correct
right well
i wish her well she does a great job in
a hacks i just didn't know
i didn't know if there was any uh
anything behind the legend uh
description
i didn't you know
even though she's a legend i go oh of
what
yeah i'm kind of digging through the
work here trying to
i don't i think it's rude to dig through
to work
if it's a woman who's been in a game for
as long as she has you just let it go
you know she's a legend
anyone's a legend right that's true
no you don't have to don't dig through
to work
she was a legend she's a legend
i'm happy for her me too maybe gene
smart should take him dalton what's his
name pruitt and bird yeah pruitt and
bird how about gene smart adopts them
maybe there should be on the next season
of hacks pruitt and bird
you know
maybe they should film the next season
of hacks in del rio texas
why don't we have that be
at the show hacks we do a comedy show
where uh gene smart
goes to do a uh
uh
fundraiser in del rio
i think that's a good topical idea
should i just start submitting ideas two
hacks yeah yeah
text them to your agent have them email
them the people that created hacks have
400 followers on twitter
so i i probably will be able to get in
touch with them if i want
i mean i imagine they don't can't make
their rent
i imagine they rent and not own
to guess
i'm guessing
i'm not trying to be a [ __ ] i'm not
saying like you know
i'm not saying that like you have to
have money to make great art in fact for
decades and centuries that was the
antithesis of the idea you know but
i'm sure they're good that people that
have created what else have they done
besides acts by the way the people that
made hacks yes people that have made
hacks let me see here jen statsky no
that's that's the uh white house press
secretary
uh paul downes and lucia enelio yeah
anello or something uh
lucia did uh broad city oh
and as well as the mini series time
traveling bong
brilliant and the 2017 film rough night
i don't know if you ever saw that i have
not who's in that i believe it's um let
me click on this what's that about
i think it's about uh tina fey and oh my
god oh wait no wait no no that's the
different movement that's different this
is uh this is a black comedy film
directed
dark comedy well i like that uh it stars
scarlett johansson zoe kravitz kate
mckinnon jillian bell alana glazer
oh okay and demi moore
interesting it follows a bachelorette
well i bet you know what now let me take
it back i bet they do have a little bit
of money
i was i was
joking around that they didn't have that
much money they they probably have a lot
of money
yeah and paul downs was from broad city
as a co-creator as well
i think hacks is actually pretty
it's decent right it's enjoyable i
enjoyed it i think it was enjoyable
i think it was enjoyable
i have no problems with any of these
people
and i imagine they have no problems with
me
or anyone that i know
i'm just saying i was confused about the
let when we kept saying gene smart was a
legend
i was i'm confused about that
that's all
it's not an attack
i think it's a question i'm allowed to
question things this is the united
states
right yes that's right but god bless
them and i'm glad their show's doing so
well that's the only comedy out right
now
it's a comedy about comedy
but that's the old the only thing that's
funny ted last was really not funny
no not at all no ted lasso's not funny
no not even a little bit
it's positive right
yeah i guess it's like it's just not
showing it's the only thing that doesn't
show people on ventilators
gasping for air and dying on the floor
so it's the only thing on tv that is
that isn't that
so i guess
by
i guess it's a comedy by default yeah
okay
and and then there's hacks yes
i'm just trying to understand the lay of
the land here
and uh i take it back when i said the
creators didn't have any money now that
i know that they have money look up her
net worth
uh which one the creator uh okay well
there's three but all i i think i know
the one you've done you're the one who
did rough night
what she got five sticks
ten sticks
i'm gonna say two sticks two million
dollars
three million dollars
uh it says here that there is not one
there's no there's not a net worth
there's no net worth
what do you get paid for doing rough
night what was the budget go to the
budget on rough night
i'm curious just how hollywood works
let me ask you a question
much like 20 million 20 million
she has to get paid money right you'd
imagine so but a lot of that probably
goes to me more
i bet most of that 20 million goes to
the drugs to just keep to me more in a
chair
right
doesn't most of that money go to the
drugs to keep demi moore in a chair yeah
right yeah i think so without having an
episode
because you know she'll have an episode
right they gotta strap her into
something
and hit her with the iv well i think
around this time she was on the h this
is 2017. well was it didn't to me more
flip out or something
uh when
i don't know
doesn't she need to be watched yes yes
she she like oh deed you know
yeah she od like uh
what was this two years ago and then she
had to go there she's gotta be watched
is my point yeah yeah she's not to be
trusted
i mean a lot of that money's got to go
for just guards to stand outside her
dressing room
do you think i'll be on the next season
of hacks or much like champion diamond
you think i've ruined that now because i
don't think the show's that bad i think
hannah einbinder does a nice job yeah
she does a fantastic i think i think
it's a good mega the uh
uh statler
yeah they do a good job on that show i
have no problem with that show
i'm just curious as to how everything
works
i'd like to have a television show why
don't you think i've been allowed to
have a television show if you had to
take a guess if you had to take a stab
at that well we've certainly tried right
and well i've tried
but you know
i don't know i think it's maybe because
um
that
people
for whatever reason
seem to not like
me
or they have an issue with me i think
they just need to take some time to get
to know you
well
perhaps
but
i also think that people are just very
risk-averse
that's what it is
i think people are risk-averse and i
think that
they associate a business relationship
with me with risk
perhaps
it's an intelligent assessment and they
think that there's too much risk in
allowing me
uh
to be part of the project yeah if they
don't know what you're gonna say next
then why would they work with you
right that's the biggest risk of them
all that's a huge
point
yeah i guess that's
that's a problem
[Laughter]
i get it i get it
you know
well
c'est la vie
you know
what does that mean such is life i think
so yeah
i want to correct myself it was in 2012
that demi moore had a seizure from a
horrific drug overdose when she did
whip-its
yeah she needs the most of the
budget of the movie rough night was to
keep demi moore from having a rough
night
you know
do you have to go babysit her she'll get
high off anything huh she'll just start
sniffing
glue i mean if you're doing whip bits to
the point you have a seizure you'll do
anything right you'll sniff glue pretty
much you don't give a [ __ ]
she'll huff paint and [ __ ] well she's
got that purple ring around her mouth
air duster she'll do computer cleaner
yeah
man
imagine having a job on that set of
trying to keep trying to get between to
me more and computer cleaner
because that's what life's about see to
me more
you're a great actress you do the whole
thing
but at the end of the day nothing's as
fun as just sucking nitrous out of a can
right yeah doesn't matter how many
awards you get or how many red carpets
how sexy you are how many people want to
[ __ ] you at the end of the day life is a
hollow
uh meaningless activity
and
we just have to
forget that and move from thing to thing
before that
truth that erodes our souls
uh comes in
so a good way to do that is suck a
nitrous out of a can
all right we got to get out of here
because room service stops at 11 and i
i'm gonna get i'm gonna be on the next
season of hacks
good night